the starting block below is 16 9 units
long so this right over here 16 9 units
long
use the tools to the right to convert
the starting block into the gold block
that is one unit long so this right over
here is one unit long you can see your
progress as the current block so how do
we convert this into one unit
well one we can start cutting it into
some pieces and let's just see what
happens so if we cut into two pieces how
big is each how big is this red section
now so if we cut this in half a half
times 16 9 this is now going to be eight
ninths
if we cut it into
four pieces
if we cut it into four pieces then this
is going to be four 9.
if we cut it into
looks like we're going to have to go all
the way to 16 pieces to get it into 1 9.
so let's cut this into 16 pieces
so now we've if you take 16 9 and if you
were to cut into 16 pieces so this is
going to be 1 9 right over here so if i
have one 9th and i want to make it a
whole how many do i need well i need 9
of them so let's do 2 9 3 9 4 9 5 9 6 9
7 9
8 9
and 9 9 and let's check our answer let's
do a couple more of these
so the starting block right over here is
1 and 9 12 units long
and we're going to use these tools to
convert the block into a gold block that
is 1 and 8 12
1 and 8 12 units long you can see your
progress as the current block
so the most obvious thing to me is if i
were to just convert the starting block
into twelfths and then i could replicate
i could copy those twelfths enough to
get to one and eight twelfths so how
many times do i have to cut this in
order to get it into just one twelfths
so one and nine twelfths is the same
thing as twelve 12 plus 9 12 which is 21
12. so if i cut this 2
into 21 blocks each of them are going to
be 1 12 because this is 21 12 right over
here so let me cut it into 21
so i will go all the way
21. so right now i cut this into 21
blocks this was 21 12. if i cut it this
is 1 21 of that so it's going to be 1
12. so this is 1 12 and now i just have
to copy it enough time to get to one and
eight twelfths
and one and eight twelfths is the same
thing as twelve twelfths plus eight
twelfths is twenty twelfths so this is
one twelfth if i get twenty of these
then it's gonna be the same length so
let me do that so it's one two 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 and
we are spot on let's check our answer
let's do one more of these this is fun
so this starting block is 11 8 units
long we want to convert into a block
that is one unit long so if i can
convert the starting block into eighths
and the way that i can make this into 1
8 is by essentially dividing it by 11.
if i have 11 8 and i divide by 11 i'm
only going to have 1 8. so let me cut
into 11 pieces
so now this is 1 8 and then if i take
this 1 8 and if i if i replicate it so i
have 8 of them 8 8 is going to be equal
to one so let me do that
two three four five six seven eight
and we got it right